welcome back to las vegas now a lot of
us are excited for santa claus but
worried about porch pirates eric
palacios of eric palacios and associates
the sponsors of this next segment have
some really important holiday safety
advice and reminders take a look
hey eric welcome back
hi thanks for having me always good to
see you it is the holiday time of course
and we have to talk holiday safety
because there's a lot of robberies and
and things going on of that nature
especially in los angeles right now so
let's talk about how to prevent this
here at home
what can you do if your package is
stolen
this happens a lot more than we'd like
to
see or admit
we see this happen on a daily basis so
it's important
to
try to make package delivery as safe as
possible so if no one is home
sometimes it's a good idea to have your
packages delivered to your work a place
of business if you're able to do that if
not if you have relatives that are
retired or that aren't working now and
are home
maybe use their address also for
delivery most delivery services now also
give you the option of delivering inside
your garage so that's also an option uh
always
never leave anything of value in the
garage and lock the house from lock the
door from your house to the garage but
if you can give them access to deliver
inside your garage that's also great as
well yeah that's a great option um a lot
of people probably don't know that so
good tip there um and speaking of you
know not leaving valuable items you know
visible especially in your car as we're
parking around town what if someone
steals something out of your car what do
you do then
this type of theft is also very common
now especially if you leave something
out in the open plain view
things you might have bought
or a purse anything of value so it's
important to cover these things up leave
them in the trunk if you absolutely have
to leave them in the car
and always be aware that there are
people looking for this type of
opportunity so if this happens you can
use your
homeowners insurance to replace the item
that was stolen most of the time that
will cover it uh if you purchased it
with a credit card then you have a
protection through your credit card as
well and sometimes they uh
give you a refund for the value of the
property damage to your car if you have
full coverage insurance you can use that
insurance to repair a broken window or
if they broke the door to get in however
most
have a deductible so that you're going
to be out of pocket for right they call
that the smash and grab right if you're
if they get into your car um great tips
and what about of course you know we
always have to be worried about porch
pirates during the holiday season and
really any time of the year but
especially now
that's very prevalent unfortunately the
best thing you can do is one uh have a
dropbox or a lock box where your
packages are delivered as i mentioned
before have them delivered within your
garage and also a big deterrent is if
you have cameras if you have a ring
doorbell system set up
that is turned on or triggered with
motion then at least you can see who did
it post it on social media and this
sometimes helps to deter the porch
pirates from attacking your house versus
your neighbors absolutely a lot of viral
videos we
have been surfacing with you know people
coming up behind you at your door so
make sure you have those cameras
installed and really just watch your
back right eric
that's it try to be as safe as possible
really good advice there thank you so
much eric palacios and associates for
sponsoring that segment for more
information give them a call at
702-444-7777